after the 1998 olympics leading up to
2002
i was worried again because nothing had
changed and i knew the makeup of the
panel so i was worried that
something was going to happen
but i didn't know what
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
course deja vu
it happened before it's happening again
it was completely obvious
we all went back to the hotel and marie
came straight through didn't acknowledge
any of us
then she ran over to me said oh sally i
was wrong i was made to judge this way
made to have the russians first
and i said well marie you've got to
report it oh no no no i can't i can't
why she couldn't i don't i can't i can't
you know she's all very very emotional
so i said well fine i'm going to report
it
so that night i i did a letter
to octavius in qantas the then president
of the international staging union
recounting exactly what marie had said
and it was delivered the next morning
[Music]
start with the topic everyone is talking
about here in salt lake city and beyond
the raging controversy surrounding
monday night's pairs competition
we have some news concerning what has
become known simply as
skate gate
did some judges strike a deal giving the
russian pair gold this amid allegations
now of collusion and result fixing
canadian broadcasting reports that the
judge met with a british skating referee
in a hotel here in salt lake city where
she reportedly revealed she was being
urged to vote in a certain way
dave comes to me and he's like oh my god
there's something going on with the
judges
the french judge he said like i it
happened so fast and that's all i
remember really knowing
somebody picked us up to be on the today
show the rest is a blur
david peltier and jamie soleil again
thank you so much for stopping by thank
you for having us i was like mom
here we go did you get any sleep at all
last night no we've been up for pretty
much 24 hours now wow what does it say
about the judging is it just that it's
extremely subjective i've never been in
their shoes and i mean we don't want to
be involved in too much controversy
we're just figure skaters that love what
they do
the isu at that time had this process
where after every competition all the
judges would get it together in a room
the next day and they'd have to come in
and say
you know here's why i gave the marks i
did then the referee could question them
mari run laguna knew she was going to go
in there to defend her marks
and i arrived in the ice rink the next
morning for the event review meeting
there were some
cameras there
they were after me
and then
i understood
i was trapped
only when i got to the ring you
understood how big it was
because we had microphones everywhere
people were trying to get in and there
was so much attention on that room it
was like a movie
in fact when the judges meeting happened
the referee put tape on the cracks of
the door so that media standing outside
couldn't overhear them
i've never seen an event review meetings
with so much tension
and i think everybody was was on the
edge of their seat
there were a lot of emotions
the american referee ron fenning read a
letter to the assembled judges which was
essentially like a guilt trip
this is a disgrace to see something like
this happening
that the canadians should have easily be
the winner that night yesterday was the
worst miscarriage of justice i've seen
in all my years of judging it was really
really straightforward that this was a
wrong result
and
this is not acceptable the judges we who
had the russian pair on the first place
were very very shocked because never
we have heard that from a referee
so it was a piece of theater
and then he says some people were
dishonest marie ren laguna says that
that word dishonest destroyed her and
she erupts in
tears and i remember the impact on that
of that world to me
it was awful how can you say that to be
treated as dishonest
and in that atmosphere she just let
loose and said that she'd been pressured
by diddy gallagher
the french federation president and she
begged for help
didi's name came out right now it's all
about this president she is under
pressure of her president she feels
sorry she regrets but she had to do this
it's all dj's fault i said what did she
say oh my god
she always said the same thing that the
judge was meeting that she said the
night before
you